[Music]
can't think yourself into writing but
you can write yourself into thinking so
just start emmy-winning writer producer
director Judd Apatow The Man Behind
almost at least half of the funny movies
you've seen this Century looking at your
IMDb I mean it's you know it's 100 miles
long from where you sit right now do you
reflect back on it and think my life is
a dream I moved to LA and I met all the
other people in comedy Adam Sandler and
Rob Schneider and David Spade and Jim
Carrey and that was like running you
know like a race with all your friends
people are interested in the struggles
of people that we're all struggling how
do you survive high school how do you
survive having a baby how do you make
your marriage work the greatest gift you
can give people is your story
[Music]